Hello, and welcome to the Video LP for my
album, "This Machine Pwns n00bs." This album
has a lot of songs on it. You can click on
any of those songs over there, and you can
go and listen to those songs on YouTube.
You can stream those songs all day and all
night for free. You can do whatever you want,
as long as you have a connection to YouTube.
And the great thing is you can also share
those songs. You can put them on your Tumblr;
you can tweet them; you can even share them
on your weblog.
It is fun, it is easy, and it's a free way
to enjoy my music. But, if you do enjoy my
music, you are welcome to buy the album if
you haven't already. It's available at dftba.com
or also on iTunes.
Also, if you would like to listen to the album
as it was designed to be listened to, you
can just click on this "Play" button, and
you will be linked to a YouTube playlist that
will play the whole freakin' album for you,
and you can, uh, clean your office... which
is what I need to do right now while listening
to good music. You don't even wanna see what
it looks like behind this.
So I'm going to shut up now, and let you
listen to the music.